>> Greg: KANYE WENT TO THE
WHITE HOUSE.
I WONDER IF THEY TRY TO SCARE
HIM INTO NOT WEARING HIS HAT.
>> THEY TRIED TO SCARE MEET TO
NOT WEAR THIS HAT, MY OWN
FRIENDS.
HIS HAT, IT GIVES ME POWER IN A
WAY.
I LOVE HILLARY.
I LOVE EVERYONE.
BUT THE CAMPAIGN "I'M WITH HER,"
DIDN'T MAKE ME FEEL, AS A GUY,
IT DIDN'T MAKE ME FEEL -- I
DIDN'T SEE MY DAD IN.
WHEN I PUT THIS HAT ON, IT MADE
ME FEEL LIKE SUPERMAN.
SUPERMAN IS MY FAVORITE
SUPERHERO.
>> Greg: WHEN THE PRESIDENT
DOESN'T LOOK GOOD, AMERICA
DOESN'T LOOK GOOD.
>> IF HE DON'T LOOK GOOD, WE
DON'T LOOK GOOD.
THIS IS OUR PRESIDENT.
HE HAS TO BE THE FRESHEST, FLY
ASKED, BEST.
WE HAVE TO MAKE OUR CORE
RE-EMPOWER.
WE HAVE TO BRING JOBS INTO
AMERICA AND WE ARE PUTTING
PEOPLE IN POSITION TO HAVE TO DO
THINGS TO END UP IN THE PRISON
SYSTEM.
>> President Trump: THAT WAS
PRETTY IMPRESSIVE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: ALL WE REALLY HAVE IS
TODAY.
>> ALL WE REALLY HAVE IS TODAY.
WE JUST HAVE TODAY.
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
THE HERO'S JOURNEY.
TRUMP IS ON HIS HERO'S JOURNEY
RIGHT AND HE MIGHT HAVE EXPECTED
TO HAVE A CRAZY [BLEEP] LIKE
KANYE WEST, HAVE SUPPORT.
BEST BELIEVE WE OUGHT TO MAKE
AMERICA GREAT.
>> Greg: JUST ANOTHER DAY IN
TRUMP WORLD.
THIS IS A NEW FRONTIER FULL OF
INCREDIBLE ALLIES AND SURREAL
SURPRISES.
AFTER BEING TOLD IT WAS GOING TO
BE THE APOCALYPSE, WE HAVE A
BOOMING ECONOMY AND RIDICULOUSLY
LOW UNEMPLOYMENT, NEW JUSTICE,
NO UGLY WARS, PROGRESS, TRADE,
PEACE IN KOREA AND YOU HAVE THE
WORLD'S BIGGEST MALE POP STAR
GOING TO THE WHITE HOUSE TO
DISCUSS BIG ISSUES AND GETTING
WHAT SEEMS TO BE A REAL
CONCESSION.
HE WOULD THINK HE WOULD RECEIVE
MEDIA ACCLAIM FOR TRYING.
YOU WOULD BE WRONG.
>> THAT WAS BONKERS.
>> IF YOU THINK YOU'RE GOING TO
GET A THOUGHTFUL PLAY-BY-PLAY
AND POLITICAL ANALYSIS, YOU'RE
NOT.
THAT WAS AN ASSAULT ON OUR
WHITE HOUSE.
>> THAT WAS CRAZY.
THAT WAS BONKERS.
>> Greg: SUCH RIDICULE BY
THOSE WHO WOULD NEVER THINK OF
TAKING SUCH RISKS.
THEY CALLED IT BONKERS AND
CRAZY.
DOG WHISTLES MEANT TO BRING UP
CONNIE'S MENTAL STATE.
SORRY, IF YOU USE MENTAL ILLNESS
IS A DISQUALIFYING FACTOR TO
EXPRESS AN OPINION, YOU WOULD
HAVE NO GUESTS ON YOUR NETWORK.
AFTER TODAY, EXPECT A PILE ON.
"SNL" WILL DO A SKIT THAT WILL
BE MUCH LESS ENTERTAINING THAN
THE REAL THING AND THE MEAN
GIRLS AT CNN WILL CALL HIM
NAMES, LIKE THEY DID LAST NIGHT.
>> HE IS AN ATTENTION WHORE LIKE
THE PRESIDENT.
HE'S THE MODEL SPOKESMAN.
HE'S THE TOKEN >> Greg: OF THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
>> Greg: WHEN YOU ARE ON TV
GIVING A HOT TAKE, HOLD OFF ON
THE ACCUSATIONS OF ATTENTION
SEEKING.
WEST CAN HANDLE IT.
THE WITH THE RISK HE IS TAKING L
THE WITH THE RISK HE IS TAKING F
THE WITH THE RISK HE IS TAKING S
HIM ABOVE AND BEYOND THE
GROUPTHINK OF THE ENTERTAINMENT
WORLD, ESPECIALLY WHEN HE DOES
THIS.
>> I LOVE THIS GUY.
LET ME GIVE THIS GUY A HUG.
I LOVE THIS GUY RIGHT HERE.
>> President Trump: THAT'S
REALLY NICE.
JIM, KANYE, I APPRECIATE IT.
LET'S GO HAVE SOME LUNCH.
>> Greg: JESSE, WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT.
THERE IS SOMETHING ACTUALLY VERY
POWERFUL -- I FOUND IT TO BE
VERY POWERFUL.
I DON'T KNOW.
>> Jesse: WAS A VERY SPECIAL
MOMENT.
THINK ABOUT THE RAW TALENT IN
THAT ROOM.
JIM BROWN, ONE OF THE GREATEST
RUNNING BACKS EVER, KANYE WEST,
ONE OF THE MOST TALENTED ARTISTS
OF ALL TIME.
AND DONALD TRUMP, TALENTED
POLITICIAN AND BUSINESSMAN.
SITTING TOGETHER AND IT WAS A
SPECIAL MOMENT.
HE PLAYED A REALLY IMPORTANT
SOUND BITE.
KANYE SAID BECAUSE CHINA HAS
STOLEN ALL OF OUR FACTORY JOBS
FROM THE INNER CITIES AND FROM
THE CORE OF AMERICA, IT'S GOTTEN
TO THE POINT WHERE YOUNG BLACK
AMERICANS ARE NOW TAKING RISKS
AND DOING ILLEGAL THINGS TO FEED
THEIR FAMILY BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO GOOD JOBS ANYMORE
AND THEY ARE GETTING PUT IN
JAIL.
IF YOU CAN SOLVE THAT PROBLEM
AND IF YOU CAN GET BLACK AMERICA
BUY INTO THE "AMERICA FIRST"
AGENDA, MADE IN AMERICA, TRADE
AGENDA, THE ENERGY AGENDA, IT'S
GOING TO HAVE A HUGE IMPACT ON
THIS COUNTRY WHERE YOU HAVE
PEOPLE COMING TOGETHER OF ALL
STRIPES AND FIGHTING FOR A
NATIONALISTIC, PATRIOTIC
ECONOMIC AGENDA FOR THE COUNTRY.
THE MEDIA IS ALREADY FRAMING IT
AS NEGATIVE, SAYING THAT IT WAS
AN ANGRY RANT.
WHEN TAYLOR SWIFT WHEN
TAYLOR SWIFT KATY PERRY, THEY DO
THOSE THINGS, THEY'RE CALLED
EXPRESSIONS, SOULFUL
EXPRESSIONS, PASSIONATE.
YOU DON'T HEAR THAT.
YOU HAVE TO KEEP IN MIND THAT
THE MEDIA IS TRYING TO TRICK
YOUR MIND AND I THOUGHT
EVERYBODY NEEDS TO WATCH THE RAW
FOOTAGE.
IT WAS MORE THAN YOU PLAYED.
IT WAS EYE-OPENING.
>> Greg: JUAN, THERE WAS A
MOMENT WHEN I THINK YOU WOULD
HAVE ADMIRED WITCHES HE WENT IN
THERE AND HE COMPLEMENTED
DONALD TRUMP AND THEN HE SLIPPED
DONALD TRUMP AND THEN HE SLIPPEI
DONALD TRUMP AND THEN HE SLIPPEN
DONALD TRUMP AND THEN HE SLIPPEW
DONALD TRUMP AND THEN HE SLIPPEA
DONALD TRUMP AND THEN HE SLIPPET
DONALD TRUMP AND THEN HE SLIPPEH
DONALD TRUMP AND THEN HE SLIPPEE
DONALD TRUMP AND THEN HE SLIPPEB
DONALD TRUMP AND THEN HE SLIPPEL
DONALD TRUMP AND THEN HE SLIPPEE
DONALD TRUMP AND THEN HE SLIPPES
DONALD TRUMP AND THEN HE SLIPPEW
IMPORTANT, THAT THEY HAD TO STOP
STOP AND FRISK IN CHICAGO
BECAUSE IT'S DESTRUCTIVE.
THE LOOK ON TRUMP'S FACE WAS
LIKE, OKAY.
YOU CAN LAUGH.
YOU CAN LOVE HIM OR HATE HIM BUT
I BELIEVE HE GOT A CONFESSION
OUT OF TRUMP.
>> Juan: I WAS GOING TO ASK,
WHAT CONCESSION?
DO YOU THINK TRUMP IS GOING TO
BACK OFF OF STOP AND FRISK?
>> Greg: TRUMP HAS GOTTEN SO
MUCH OUT OF THIS.
I THINK THERE'S A GENUINE
AFFECTION BETWEEN THESE TWO MEN
THAT HE WILL PROBABLY GET
SOMETHING OUT OF IT, IN EXCHANGE
FOR SOMETHING ELSE.
>> Juan: I DIDN'T SEE ANY
MAJOR CONCESSION ON THE TABLE
BECAUSE I DIDN'T SEE SUBSTANCE.
INSTEAD, I SEE A CELEBRITY.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND -- I THINK
THE OVAL OFFICE SHOULD BE
TREATED WITH SOME RESPECT AND
THE IDEA THAT HE GOES IN THERE
AND HE'S USING SUCH AWFUL
LANGUAGE, I DON'T THINK THAT'S
VERY COOL.
>> Jesse: WAS BILL CLINTON
RESPECTFUL OF THE OFFICE?
>> Juan: HERE'S THE THING
ABOUT THIS GUY.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY IT IS
THAT, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE WOULD
THINK THIS IS ABOUT THE BLACK
COMMUNITY.
TO THE CONTRARY.
THIS IS TRUMP I THINK SPEAKING
TO HIS WHITE BACKERS AND SAYING
I'M NOT A RACIST.
>> Jedidiah: COME ON.
>> Juan: KANYE WEST IS HERE
WITH ME SO --
ALL THESE THINGS ABOUT ME
CALLING PEOPLE DOGS AND COMING
FROM S-HOLE COUNTRIES, DON'T
WORRY ABOUT IT.
>> Greg: IF A WHITE PERSON IS
HAVING A CONVERSATION WITH A
BLACK LEADER, YOUR ANSWER IS
TO --
>> Juan: THIS BEHAVIOR BY
TRUMP DIDN'T START YESTERDAY.
HE HAD BLACK PEOPLE COMING IN,
LIKE JIM BROWN, STEVE HARVEY.
AND KANYE WEST.
AT TRUMP TOWER.
WHAT CAME OUT OF IT?
ZERO.
THIS IS THE POINT.
>> Greg: IT'S CALLED PROGRESS.
>> Juan: PROGRESS IN TERMS OF
TRUMP SAYING FORGET ALL THE
THINGS I'VE DONE.
I HAVE A BLACK FRIEND,
KANYE WEST.
>> Jedidiah: IF KANYE WANTED
TO GO TO THE WHITE HOUSE AND
TALKED TO TRUMP, HE WOULD BE
LABELED RACIST.
IF KANYE WANTS TO GO TO THE
WHITE HOUSE AND TALK TO TRUMP,
HE'S LABELED RACIST.
YOU HAVE TO GIVE KANYE CREDIT.
I DON'T ALWAYS AGREE WITH HIM
THEN SOMETIMES I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT HE'S SAYING BUT
HE GOES IN AND SPEAKS HIS MIND
AND KANYE WEST KNOWS HE'S GOING
TO BE ABUSED BY EVERYBODY IN
HOLLYWOOD AND EVERYONE IN HIS
BUBBLE, THEY'RE GOING TO MAKE
FUN OF HIM AND BERATE HIM AND HE
DOESN'T CARE AND FRANKLY THAT IS
INSPIRATIONAL.
WE SHOULD BE TELLING EVERYBODY
IF YOU HAVE SOMETHING TO SAY,
YOU WANT TO TALK TO THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
AND HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY, EVEN
IF YOU DON'T AGREE AND YOU CAN
PUT POLICY ON THE TABLE, STOP
AND FRISK OR WHATEVER.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT STOP AND
FRISK.
IT'S AN ACCOMPLISHED --
ACCOMPLISHMENT.
>> Juan: WHEN YOU HAVE THIS
GUY SAYING LET'S DO AWAY WITH
THE 13TH AMENDMENT WHICH ENDED
SLAVERY IN THIS COUNTRY, YOU
THINK I THINK SOMETHING IS
WRONG.
>> Greg: THERE WERE SEVEN
SUBSTANCE ON THAT.
IS HE SOMEONE SOMEONE WILLING TO
SACRIFICE HIS COOL CREDENTIALS B
SACRIFICE HIS COOL CREDENTIALS C
SACRIFICE HIS COOL CREDENTIALS U
SACRIFICE HIS COOL CREDENTIALS E
HE BELIEVES IN IT.
IN THE MESSAGE IS NOT A SINGLE
NEGATIVE MESSAGE.
>> Dana: WHEN YOU ARE IN A
POSITION WHERE YOU HAVE THE
FREEDOMS AND THE FINANCIAL
SECURITY TO BE ABLE TO TAKE A
RISK AND DO WHAT YOU WANT, YOU
CAN BE A LEADER IN A DIFFERENT
WAY.
I ALSO THINK EVERYONE NEEDS TO
SLEEP ON IT.
WAKE UP IN THE MORNING AND
LISTEN TO OTHER PEOPLE.
JUAN FEELS PASSIONATELY AND I'M
SURE A LOT OF PEOPLE AROUND THE
COUNTRY DO.
THEN GO BACK -- YESTERDAY
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS AT THE
INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
CHIEFS OF POLICE IN FLORIDA.
HE LOVES THE POLICE.
HE SUPPORTS THE POLICE.
HE SAYS THE ONLY ADMINISTRATION
THAT'S BEHIND YOU, THAT
HYPERBOLE BUT PART OF IT IS
TRUSTING THE POLICE TO DO
SOMETHING.
KANYE WEST SAYS I DON'T LIKE
STOP AND FRISK.
MAYBE THE PRESIDENT BECAUSE HE
HAS THE POWER OF CONVENING,
BRING PEOPLE TOGETHER.
WHAT'S IMPORTANT IS TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE TWO SIDES TALK.
STOP AND FRISK ISN'T GOING TO
STOP BECAUSE POLICE THINK IT'S
EFFECTIVE.
UNLESS THERE'S A SITUATION WHERE
YOU GO TO COURT.
>> Greg: I MENTION THREE WEEKS
AGO THAT COLIN KAEPERNICK SHOULD
GO TO THE WHITE HOUSE AND MEET
WITH TRUMP, AND THAT WAS THE
OTHER THING THE KANYE WEST SAID.
HIS GOAL IS TO BRING KAEPERNICK
AND TRUMP TOGETHER, CONVENING.
>> Dana: THIS WHITE HOUSE IS
VERY TELEVISION SAVVY.
SOMETIMES THEY SET UP SHOTS THEY
DO NOT WORK FOR THEM.
THIS ONE IS INTERESTING.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS BEHIND THE
DESK.
USUALLY WHEN HE HAS A MEETING
WITH SOMEBODY IN THE
OVAL OFFICE, HE IS WITH A WORLD
LEADER OR SOMEONE, NIKKI HALEY,
THEY WERE IN THE CHAIRS.
THE PRESIDENT KNEW.
HE DIDN'T ELEVATE KANYE WEST TO
THAT LEVEL.
I'M GOING TO SIT BEHIND THE DESK
AND WERE GOING TO HAVE A MEETING
AT THE SHOP, THE WAY IT'S SET
UP, THE ONLY PEOPLE IN THE SHOT,
YOU CAN SEE PRESIDENT TRUMP A
LITTLE BIT.
THE PROFILE OF KANYE WEST AND
ALL OF THE MEDIA.
IT WAS INTERESTING TO WATCH WITH
THE SOUND OFF, AS I DID, WHEN I
WAS GETTING HAIR AND MAKEUP DON
DONE.
I THOUGHT IT'S THE CRAZIEST
THING I'VE EVER SEEN, NOT IN A
BAD WAY.
IT WAS DIFFERENT.
WE ARE IN A TIME OF
EXTRAORDINARY ECONOMIC
PROSPERITY.
YOU CAN SOLVE PROBLEMS LIKE THE
ONES THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT.
YOU CONVENE PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO
TALK ABOUT IT.
WE ARE NOT AT EACH OTHER'S
THROATS FOR CERTAIN THINGS.
WHEN YOU HAVE PEACE AND
PROSPERITY, YOU CAN DEAL WITH
THESE THINGS.
>> Greg: MIGHT I QUOTE SCOTT
ADAMS?
HE SAID WE DON'T HAVE A MONEY